we've got a scale here and as you see
the scale is balanced and we have a
question to answer we have this mystery
mass over here it's a big question mark
on this on this blue mass right over
here and we also have a bunch of one i
guess we could call them one kilogram
masses so these are all each a one
kilogram mass and my question to you is
what could we do to either side of the
scale in order to figure out what the
mystery mass is or maybe we can't figure
out at all is there something that we
can do either removing or adding these
things so that we can figure out what
this mystery mass is and i'll give you a
couple of seconds to think about that
well to figure out what this mystery
mass is we essentially just want this on
one side of this scale but that by
itself isn't enough we could just remove
these three but that won't do the job
because if we just removed these three
then the left hand side of the scale is
clearly going to have less mass and it's
going to go up and the right side is
going to go down and that's not going to
give us much information it's just going
to tell us that this that this blue
thing has a lower mass than what's over
here so just removing this won't help us
much it won't let us know that this is
equal to that what we've got to do if we
want to keep the scale balanced is we've
got to remove the same amount of mass
from both sides of the scale so if we
want to remove three things here so let
me try my best to remove three things
here if we want to remove three
let me do it like this i'll just color
i'll just erase it so if we want to
remove three things there if we did this
by itself just removed these three
things then the two sides would not have
an equal mass anymore this side over
here would have a lower mass so we've
got to remove 3 from both sides so if we
really want to make sure that our scale
is balanced we've got to remove 3 from
both sides and so if we start it off
with the scales balanced
and then we remove 3 from both sides the
scale will still be balanced and then
when we do that we have a clear idea of
what the mass of this object actually is
now when we remove 3 from both sides the
scale will still be balanced and we know
that this mass is equal to whatever is
left over over here it's equal to one
two three four five six
seven and if we're assuming they're
kilograms we'll know that the question
mark mass the question mark is equal to
seven kilograms that this right over
here is a seven kilogram mass